Ready start Book
Niso
dee
uh
Today
Loss Yuru-chara Ask the challenger a question here
How will they swim?
It really seems like it's going to be quick
a Come back, have you caught any fish?
I thought it would be quicker, but it's not.
It's deadly
in the ocean. Those with long legs seem to have gotten cold in the ocean.
You'll get stronger, so wolves do that too. Come to think of it,
wait, then
your short legs won't be able to stand on the ice
longer. There's a reason they made their legs longer.  You can bend down your hot arteries and share the heat.If your
legs are short, you can't take a long time in this temperature-sharing zone.
But there's no sign of it falling over.Isn't the counter cold?